on a une enfant de la république désolé
par 20 militaires c'est un scandale
d'état
voilà
[Musique]
la justice la méprise depuis dix ans
elle dit qu'elle n'a pas le sentiment
d'être traitée en victime mais d'être
coupable c'est elle qu'on on passe au
peigne fin dans tous les sens et mon
passé c'est l'agresseur puisque il faut
rappeler que les dix-sept mon pied n'ont
jamais été mis en examen et donc aucune
en fait amp aucune enquête n'a été faite
à leur encontre
[Musique]
m
oh
on
un enfant même même jusqu'à 15 ans voire
16 ans est incapable de pouvoir
consentir un acte sexuel avec la vie un
adulte à un pouvoir sur un enfant ce
n'est pas une relation d'égalité
[Musique]
il
juni à lattes en maintenant leur santé
la france c'est d'institutions mais
rendent justice
[Musique]